confucius had a great saying that uh you
know every man has two lives and the
second starts when he realizes he has
just one
wow
and i read that it was one of those book
dropping lines you know it's like mic
drop confucius had a lot of mic drops
fuchsias was a bad [ __ ] he was
that's a crazy one that was a great one
um or another one is next time you get
sick you know because everybody gets
sick every now and then it's like a
happy person
wants 10 000 things a sick person just
wants one thing
right so it's your it's your unlimited
desires that are clouding your peace
your happiness
have desires your biological creature
stands up and says i can do something i
i move i resist i live
but
just be very careful of your desires
this is the oldest most trite wisdom
desire is suffering that's what it means
right every desire you have is an access
where you will suffer so just don't
focus on more than one desire at a time
the universe is rigged in such a way
that if you just want one thing and you
focus on that you'll get it but
everything else you gotta let go
did you make a gradual shift to
happiness or was it a radical change
it's ongoing it's gradual every day so
you're happier today than you were a
month ago yeah allegedly yeah
yeah i'm i'm very happy these days
deliriously so it's actually hard for me
to hang out with normal people really
yeah so you you've made a significant
shift
over the period of like how many years
about eight years eight years yeah
wow and
is this something that you've pursued
through certain books or is it just like
you you've made an understanding or
gained an understanding in your own mind
and then started pursuing it based on
that understanding yeah it's very very
personal uh it's basically you have to
decide it's a priority and then i tried
every hack i possibly could i used to
you know i tried all the i tried
meditation i tried witnessing uh you
know i even tried an ssri just to see
what it would feel like how did it feel
uh it was it turned me from a pessimist
to an optimist but i didn't like the
physical side effects nor did i want to
be on a drug for a sustained basis
so i dropped it and i did turn you into
an optimist yes at the time i used to be
a pessimist yeah
um i started doing things like i would
start looking at the you know in every
moment and everything that happens you
can look on the bright side of something
right and so i used to do that forcibly
and then i trained it until it became
second nature so for example like a
friend of my wife's was over and she
when we were dating and she took all
these photos she took like hundreds of
photos and then she sends them all to us
and my immediate reaction was like why
are you dumping hundreds of photos of my
phone i don't need hundreds of photos
have some judgment that's my immediate
reaction and then i could say actually
how nice of her she sent me hundreds of
photos i can pick the one that i like
right there are two ways of seeing
almost everything there are a few things
that are like high suffering so you
can't do that other than just saying
well this is a teacher right but i
slowly worked through every negative
judgment that i had until i saw the
positive and now it's second nature to
me i also realized that like what you
want is you want to clear minds you want
to let go of thoughts
happy thoughts disappear out ahead
automatically very easy to let go of
them negative thoughts linger so if you
interpret the the positive and
everything very quickly you let it go
right you let it go much faster
hacks get more sunlight right learn to
smile more learn to hug more these
things actually release serotonin in
reverse they aren't just outward signals
of being happy they're actually feedback
loops to being happy
spend more time in nature you know these
are obvious watch your mind watch your
mind all day long watch what it does not
judge it not try to control it but you
can meditate 24 7. meditation is not a
sit down close your eyes activity
meditation is just basically watching
your own thoughts like you would watch
anything else in the outside world and
say why am i having that thought does
that serve me anymore is that
conditioning from when i was 10 years
old like for example
getting ready for this podcast you got
ready i didn't but good i did but i did
but i did i couldn't help it and what
happened was the few days leading up to
this my mind was just running and
normally my mind is pretty calm and it
was just running and running and running
and every thought i would have i would
imagine me saying it to you my brain
couldn't help but rehearse
what what it's doing it's just
rehearsing all the time to talk to you
and then i was even rehearsing rehearse
telling you about the rehearsal right so
it was all playing all these meta games
and i was just like shut up stop it what
is going on and it took me a while to
figure out oh yeah you know what it is
when i was a kid in queens and i had no
money and i had nothing and i needed to
save myself the way i got out was by
sounding smart not being smart sounding
smart that was the skill i perfected so
i am hardwired to always rehearse things
so i will sound smart it's a disease it
keeps me from being happy so but when
you see that when you realize that when
you understand something then it
naturally calms you down so after that i
stopped rehearsing as much
wow but it's still a train habit
that is a really interesting point that
you
want to sound smart
that that many people do that and
especially young people when you you see
someone who is smart or someone who
appears smart they say smart things oh
god i want to sound smart i want people
to think about me the same way i think
about that person that is my disease
that is my feeling it is what clutters
my mind i the the thing i have to ask
myself now is
if i can
would i still be interested in learning
this thing if i couldn't ever tell
anybody about it
that's how i know it's real that's how i
know it's something i actually want to
know that's a common thing though i know
i suffered from that when i was young
the desire to sound smart
that's it's very
it's very common
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you